congrats though on everything I I
literally I was I was late to the game
on getting to watch White Lotus congrats
on it because I I literally got sick for
like three weeks I feel like and I was
like oh my god I've never gotten to
watch this whole state I watched the
whole thing like back to back it was so
good so talented do you feel like
because I've known you for a while I
feel like like since you were little
like and so I've been watching you for a
minute but some people are like oh my
God she's amazing and just discovering
you do you feel like it was like do you
feel like it's been a long road to have
that Moment Like A White Lotus moment
yeah I mean I think I've had a lot of
ups and downs in my career like anyone I
mean this career is you probably oh
music I mean well yeah you're amazing oh
no I think every career has a little bit
of ups and downs and so I feel in a way
like I've been discovered over and over
and over it's kind of cool sort of but
but there's always that and I think with
the Emmy nomination with White Lotus I
you know it's like it's sort of like
overnight being discovered but you've
been thinking for 20 years so I just
think it's about doing what you love and
and doing it for the right reasons and
um and then you know hopefully it all
works out but it's been it's been really
special for me I feel really lucky yeah
it is funny though when you said sort of
I was like yeah that's kind of like when
I go somewhere and I sing somewhere and
they're like oh my you're a good singer
and I'm like ah
okay I think it's been a minute but all
right like oh wow
do you have a record and I'm like I well
and then you're like good but it's like
it's one of those things where you do
you feel like you've been working but
sometimes people do they're just
discovering you for whatever reason they
haven't seen or whatever heard or
whatever yeah it is kind of cool though
I think in the sense of like you have
time to really create who you are and
who you want to be publicly and you're
not like right off the bat known for
just one thing and you're kind of
beholden to that so that's kind of cool
yeah it's very cool and I think also I'm
getting you know as you get older
there's whole new generations of people
sort of learning who you are and
disguise you you get the answering yeah
yeah and you get to sort of recreate
your career yourself
um that's fun but I I I don't I've just
been lucky I don't put that much and I
White Lotus was I was so lucky yeah what
a cool show to be part of yeah
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]